well hammy need to buy you dinner Jed
the Iranian ambassador to the UK joins
us from Westminster studio good evening
thank you for talking to us so the world
is clearly very concerned the UK's
Foreign Secretary thinks that what
you're doing now is a breach of the deal
and it and it poses a risk to our
security why are you doing this we are
doing this because we want to salvage
the nuclear deal from total collapse
because in fact the other side's have
not been able to live up with their
obligations and Iran is resorting to to
certain actions to ensure that this deal
would not be totally collapse so we are
reducing some of our commitments to give
warnings to the other sides that this
situation cannot be continued and urge
them to completely agree to implement
their shares of commitments so my
question is is taking another step and
further enriching uranium is that the
best way to persuade people that you
actually want this deal to continue
there there could be three scenarios
when the other parties are not
implementing their shares of commitments
either we should be silent about this
situation and we should and we would
continue our obligations regardless of
the situation that the other parties are
not implementing their shares of
commitments that scenario is not a
sustainable situation the second
scenario is that Iran would be withdraw
from the deal and totally abandon the
deal which would be leading to a total
collapse and the third scenario is that
Iran would be reducing its obligations
in response to the total lack of
implementation of the commitments from
other sides so we are trying to ensure
that the the jcpoa would not mean in
total collapse and hopefully the other
side would
back to implementing their shares of
commitments so Donald Trump says he
wants to renew renegotiate a new nuclear
deal which will also halt the
development of ballistic missiles are
you open
is Iran open to renegotiating the deal
and including the issue of ballistic
missiles we believe that in fact
renegotiation of a deal would be again
would lead to a collapse of the of the
nuclear deal in its totality we should
be abide by the agreement that which has
been adopted after intensive years of
negotiations and we should be backing to
the implementing of our commitments we
don't think that this is a reliable
solution that we would Reagan ago she
ate such a deal which in our view would
be leading to another sets of
uncertainties but will you sit down with
the Americans will you sit with your
leaders sit down with Donald Trump or do
you do you do not trust Donald Trump in
fact we have negotiated with the
Americans through in intensive talks
that we have had in fact during the
Vienna process so we would be ready to
see what are the problems on the
condition that the United States would
be back to the nuclear deal and in fact
try to reassure the other parties that
they are in fact ready to implement
their shares of commitments so do you
want you're saying that can't be talks
unless Donald Trump lifts the sanctions
that he is reimpose don you is that what
you're saying yes no country can in fact
be pressurized to negotiations
negotiations should be on there a normal
situation with a view to resolve the
issue so the United States want to
pressure
Iran to accept to negotiate on their
forced terms which is not possible
Iran is is a is a party which has been
complying with its commitments and would
be ready in fact to to sit with all
other parties to resolve the remaining
issues but the all parties should be
committing and and implement fully their
obligations I will see the Americans say
the it's a broader issue and that you
continue to attack Saudi Arabian oil
facilities ships in the Gulf and now
you're doing this they say that you're
seeking conflict in some way with the
u.s. of course we we see these as
accusations and unfounded in fact
accusations that they are leveling
against Iran and this is not new to us
but the question is that these are
separate issues we have negotiated on
nuclear deal to resolve the nuclear
issue of course Iran would be the first
country to be ready to discuss the
regional issues and we have submitted in
fact a proposal to the United Nations to
initiate a [ __ ] most peace plan which
would be engaging all countries in the
region for a dialogue and cooperation on
security and peace issues right I mean
and if Donald Trump doesn't lift the
sanctions and you carry on you know with
what you're doing your nuclear
facilities how far will you go to
reinstate your program will you go back
to what it was or will you go even
further it depends on other parties we
have we have determined that in fact we
want to salvage the nuclear deal and
these measures that Iran is or adopting
Iran is adopting is exactly trying to
urge the other sides that they should be
in fact living up with their obligations
but the salvage of the nuclear deal
which is
very important issue for Iran we hope
that they would the other parties also
would be valuing in fact similarly and
if that would be determination by all
parties I think we have a quick solution
because the measures that Iran would
would be adopting are all reversible and
we have adopted in fact reversible
measures and just finally 30 seconds
don't you have to talk your currency is
plummeting your exports are collapsing
inflation soaring you have to talk now
there's no real alternative other than
possible conflict our economies is doing
much better comparing to the last year
which in fact the sanctions were imposed
against Iran
we are regaining our full confidence in
being able to recover our economy and we
are at the right track so we would be
not negotiating on there these
circumstances and we would but we we
would not be negotiating on the forced
measures by the United States or maximum
pressure as they call it all right mr.
ambassador thank you for joining us this
evening